ce qu'il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de
ratés pendant ces neuf ans oui j'étais
pour le long de regarder vendre atc pas
à les salariés annaba voilà c'est la
balle avec nous ce soir à ghadames à la
fiche des seigneurs et bientôt deux
millions d'entre deux millions d'autres
et ça c'est une belle expérience
bah oui ça j'avais des cheveux bizarres
dans son
[Applaudissements]
et je voudrais pas traire
laisse encore rentrés chez eux donc de
ces jeunes voient la télé mais qu'est-ce
qu'il a passée voilà c'est noël ce qu'il
a à moitié ok c'est l'espace bernard les
chéris arrêté je ne sais pas qui était à
tout va bien alors c'est télé ne vaut
d'ailleurs été en régie les chéris
qu'est ce qui se passe s'il vous plaît
je n'ai rien fait rien fait je vous jure
je n'avais rien à perdre à moi ça n'est
pas vrai vous commander à distance à
gérer leurs codes il ya du nom n'est pas
moi je vous le jure
regardez comme c'est moi ça fait ça
voilà là c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi
voilà c'est pas moi c'est pas moi s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît on se calme
j'aimerais aller voir ce qui se passe en
région mena
du bilan car ni les emmener là où va oui
dommage la veste
merde les mains quand les mecs qu'est ce
qui se passe à guy forget là qu'est ce
qui se passe en régie là haut c'est qui
qui qui est le responsable
c'est qu'ils n'ont jamais ce que j'ai
pas testé en cette question qu'est ce
qu'il ya j'ai pas fait exprès en fait
parce qu'on sait du stagiaire à l'oeuf
il y en a dit il faut valoriser les
maîtres de la lumière mais mais mais
mais c'est magnifique mais j'adore
laurent batik et la bosnie d'amour pour
elle et on a dit de tu fais un petit
coup de main tu fais ce que tu veux toi
tu venir avec mon bateau tu veux rester
ici n'a pour l'instant faut que je me
familiarise parce que je voudrais pas
envoyé de la mousse sur les gens
d'accord alors dans le fond que
j'apprenne justesse qu'on peut donner un
micro à laurent baffie tu peux
intervenir quand tu veux dans l'émission
avec tu veux dire tout ce que tu veux
que je t'aime ou de changer ça va
commencer
[Applaudissements]
laurent batik et avec nos
applaudissements pour les bravo merci je
regardais scellier 9 tonne qui sont
cachalot des yeux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]